It's almost time to go, but before we do,
we like to leave you with a little something
to take on the go in the Doggy Bag.
(Ross growling and barking)
(audience applauding and cheering)
There he goes.
And today it's an incredible nonprofit
that we featured in the current magazine that I make.
Yes, it has my name on it.
Just a Kind Note is recruiting letter writers
to be part of their movement
to spread kindness one note at a time.
And you can sign up with a commitment
to write at least three notes a month,
and they'll hook you up with addresses
for some people who could really use some kindness,
elderly people, college kids,
first responders, small business owners,
and it's designed to require no response
from those who get the letters.
Just kindness with no strings attached.
And they've already sent out 18,000 notes, Rossy.
Wow, okay, I'm in, I'm in.
I know, I wanna do this too.
Let's do it.
All right, okay.
Hopefully, maybe someone will wanna join in
on this wonderful cause.
And thank you to all our guests for being here
at the studio today.
And everybody watching at home
(audience cheering)
or on the go,
we're so honored that you choose
to spend your time with us.
Take this good energy with you.
That's what you take on the go.
We'll see you, too.
(upbeat music)